بعد اقل من ثلاثه اشهر على شرائه تويتر
اعلن ايلون ماسك في تغريد انه سيترك رئاسه
الشركه
ساتنحي عن منصب الرئيس التنفيذي بمجرد ان
اجد شخصا مجنونا بما يكفي لتولي الوظيفه
بعد ذلك ساقول فرق البرامج والخادم
قرار ياتي بعد استفتاء اطلقه الى الماسك
بنفسه يوم الاحد يقول هل استقيل مالك
تويتر تعاهد باحترام النتائج بعد 24 ساعه
وبمشاركه اكثر من 17 مليون شخص ظاهره
النتيجه اكثر من
57% من الناخبين يؤيدون استقالته القرار
ياتي وسط فوضى ماليه واداريه في تويتر منذ
توليه المنصب فقال ماسك نصف كبار الموظفين
عادت تفعيل حسابات معلقه والغا سياسه
مكافحه المعلومات المظلله بشان كوفي 19
شركات تويتر تمر بازمه من عكس على شركات
اخرى لماسك بدا من تسلا في غضون ثلاثه
اشهر فقدت الشركه المصنعه لسيارات
الكهربائيه اكثر من نصف قيمتها